and our first story tonight concerns the
fact that this week saw the leak of a
draft opinion written by justice samuel
alito that looks set to strike down roe
v wade and while the fate of roe may not
have been a surprise the draft itself
was still a horror show
the 67 page draft opinion is clear sharp
and scornful declaring in its opening
paragraphs that roe versus wade must be
overruled and that the 1972 ruling was
egregiously wrong from the start the
leader dismisses the argument in roe
versus wade that the right to choose
abortion is part of the constitutional
guarantee of liberty and privacy
insisting the inescapable conclusion is
that the right to abortion is not deeply
rooted in the nation's history and
traditions okay but even if that were
true which by the way [ __ ] off the
framers probably left off the specific
right to abortion because they couldn't
anticipate it being such a massive
concern i don't know why these
particular individuals didn't have
abortion on the forefront of their minds
there must have been some explanation i
just can't quite place the exact reason
but it is on the tip of my penis and
look
alito wasn't just deferring to the
constitution he repeatedly cited some
other notable sources too like 17th
century jurist sir matthew hale who once
described abortion as a great crime but
that is not all that hale thought he
also argued that a husband cannot be
guilty of a rape committed upon his wife
sentenced two women to death for
witchcraft and argued young women were
the ruin of families because they and i
quote learn to be bold and talk loud and
while those beliefs might only weigh
netflix comedy special called trigger
this they should absolutely disqualify
you as a scholarly reference on a matter
of reproductive rights and look this is
not the first time that we've talked
about abortion on this show in fact the
first time that we talked about it in
depth we rewarded anyone for sticking to
the end of our story with a video of
sloths playing in a bucket that was
almost criminally joyful and if you're
expecting something similar this time
i've got some bad news for you those
sloths are dead now
all of them two from heroin it's time to
grow up because we need to be able to
talk about abortion like adults because
when as now seems inevitable this ruling
becomes official there will be immediate
and devastating consequences and it is
worth taking some time tonight to talk
about a few things what this ruling
means how we got to this point and where
we go now and when it comes to what this
means
it's catastrophic it'll quickly trigger
bounds on abortion in these 22 states
and if you are still unaware of just how
ubiquitous a procedure this is an
estimated 25 percent of women have an
abortion and six in ten of them are
already parents some who get abortions
are survivors of rape or incest others
might need one for medical reasons but
also just to be clear
some will be seeking an abortion because
they [ __ ] want one and this is very
much about them too this is a fight for
people's right to have control over
their bodies it's about bodily autonomy
and the only time it's okay to argue
against that is if the body in question
belongs to el mog because then
it is actually fine he literally cannot
function unless someone else is armed
[ __ ] him from below but
anything beyond that example is just not
okay
and some conservatives have argued that
the reaction this week has been
hysterical that this is just returning
the issue to the states and the people
do still have a choice
this is not an opinion by the way that
is going to undo abortion in this
country states may put some more
restrictions on it but people have the
right to leave they can go live
somewhere else where it's more of a
free-for-all and they can do whatever
they want okay first where it's more of
a free-for-all
let's just get one thing straight if you
move to delaware you're not in some
bacchanalian buy one get one free
abortion paradise you're just in
wilmington i just don't want anyone to
be disappointed when they visit but also
it's not about merely having the right
to go somewhere else it's about whether
you have the resources and ability to do
that and many may not with this
disproportionately affecting those with
disabilities or who are transgender
immigrants or people of color and the
thing is even with just the existing
laws that have been recently passed
abortions had become increasingly
difficult to get just watch as one woman
in texas learned what getting an
abortion would entail for her after her
state passed its so-called fetal
heartbeat law last year
you're measuring at 6.1 weeks today but
we do see fetal cardiac activity on
ultrasound
so as of september 1st in texas what
that means is that you are ineligible to
have an abortion in the state of texas
right now your next options would be
traveling out of state to get the
procedure done i didn't even know that i
was pregnant i kind of just took a test
i'm six weeks and one day pregnant
i'm not ready to have another kid i have
two other little ones
that i take care of by myself
um
so this kind of was very unexpected
other forms of birth control failed me
and now it looks like i'm jumping
through
more hoops in order to
keep our lives going
six weeks and a day and she can't get an
abortion for most people that is a
period that is two weeks late and your
period could be two weeks late for any
number of reasons maybe you're tired or
traveling or you had a change in diet or
exercise or maybe you're just dealing
with the stress of living in a
misogynistic theocracy run by five of
the biggest weirdos in the country
including justice beerpong here and
justice my wife helped plan a coup and
all i got was no consequences whatsoever
now in that woman's particular case she
was able to take a loan and drive all
the way to oklahoma to get an abortion
and as awful as this sounds she was
actually lucky there because now that is
no longer possible just this week
oklahoma's governor signed a texas-style
abortion ban into law which is
officially now one of the worst things
that oklahoma has ever produced and i'll
remind you it also gave the world doctor
[ __ ] phil
and given given that half of those who
have abortions are below the poverty
line with an additional one quarter very
close to it many will be facing limited
options one estimate is that in the year
after the ruling there'll be roughly 75
000 people who want but can't get
abortions and will give birth instead
and inevitably some of those people will
die because pregnancy is a major medical
event
already those living in states with the
most restrictive abortion policies and
thus the least access to them were found
to be more likely to die while pregnant
or shortly thereafter look i know this
is all extremely grim but it is now
worth taking a moment on exactly how we
got to this point especially as some
have been telling a slightly incomplete
story this week just listen to chuck
schumer pointing the finger of blame
firmly in one direction this isn't your
grandfather's republican party america
it's donald trump's republican party
well hold on there because in what way
is this not your grandfather's
republican party it has been advocating
for this exact outcome for decades now
in fact i would be willing to bet that
if your grandfather died in the 70s came
back to life right now and scans the
news the first thing he say is that the
current republican party sounds exactly
like the one he remembers actually i
take that back the first thing he'd say
is who's elon musk to which you'd say oh
he's a he's a rich [ __ ] who wants to
own twitter to which he'd say what's
twitter and you'd say it's basically a
massive public toilet that people [ __ ]
their bad opinions into all day long but
at least cher is on there too to which
he replied oh you mean sonny's wife and
you'd say yeah because you don't really
have time to fill him in on the divorce
much less the accident to which you'd
say how's sonny doing by the way to
which you say oh yeah he's great he's
very healthy to which he replied does he
still have the mustache and you say oh
yeah you betcha because at this point
you are way too deep into the lie to
admit to your resurrected grandpa that
sonny bono died by skiing into a tree
but then after all of that conversation
he'd definitely look at you and say that
the current republican party sounds
exactly like the one that he remembers
because it does
this is just not a recent development at
all because while yes trump did pick one
third of this court including a seat for
gorsuch that was stolen for him that was
the result of decades of work by
anti-abortion forces long before trump
ever even considered running for office
conservatives were openly announcing
their intention to overturn roe in fact
the very day the road decision was
handed down the strategizing against it
had already begun just watch this news
report from that day featuring a lawyer
talking about a lawsuit that he was
supporting that could overturn roe
what about the child's right you know
when you talk about the woman's right
you're talking about one-third of the
rights involved the mother the father
and the child somebody's morality or
lack of it is certainly imposed upon the
unborn children who are killed
wow
women have one third of the rights
involved honestly that is kind of
perfect because if there is one thing
that we love to do in america it's
turned everyone who isn't a straight
white man into a [ __ ] fraction that
is something that truly is deeply rooted
in the nation's history and traditions
but arguments like that are why some
democrats like representative bella
abzug argued in the wake of the role
decision that congress still needed to
quickly pass legislation codifying the
right to an abortion and she was
absolutely right but of course they
didn't do that nor did they do it as the
anti-abortion movement kicked into high
gear in the late 1970s with the support
of evangelical leaders like jerry
falwell who helped elevate the abortion
issue as a way of motivating
conservative voters to the polls they
didn't even do it as anti-abortion
legislators
managed to pass a thousand restrictions
into law at the state level all that
time
too many democratic leaders shied away
from engaging in that fight or were
squeamish in their defense of abortion
bill clinton for instance argued that it
should be safe legal and rare which cast
abortion as a regrettably necessary evil
not a cornerstone of comprehensive
health care and while later barack obama
campaigned on passing the freedom of
choice act enshrining the rights to
abortion into law when he was reminded
of that promise a hundred days into his
presidency he wasted no time distancing
himself from it
the freedom of choice act is not my
highest legislative priority i believe
that
women should have the right to choose
but
i think that
the most important thing we can do
to tamp down some of
the um
the anger
surrounding this issue
uh is to focus on those areas that we
can agree on
okay except that's just ridiculous
partly because this is something a
majority of americans do agree on polls
consistently show that around two-thirds
of americans support the roe v wade
decision two-thirds
presidents can't even get an approval
rating that high unless there are like
two 911s it's called in 1822 and if
we're honest it might actually be coming
and that is sadly been emblematic of
democrats approach offering vague
statements in support while abortion has
been specifically under attack and all
the while republicans have focused on
this issue with relentless determination
here is jerry falwell right after alito
was appointed to the court taking a
victory lap following a ruling that
upheld the ban on a specific abortion
procedure
that is the culmination for me of about
35 years of work i don't think we have
five votes on roe v wade i think we're
probably one or two votes short
as we talked that last week of his life
falwell seemed to recognize that his
battle to end all abortions would have
to be won by the next generation of
god's warriors
my children
are more likely to see
this
this victory one than i am
i think we're 50 years away
we've got to stay with it stay with it
stay with it
and never give up
wow
even the truly magnificent sight of
jerry falwell in a coffin somehow still
doesn't make that go down any easier
because falwell was actually pessimistic
in his prediction there they achieved
that victory 35 years ahead of his
50-year schedule and that's actually not
the only thing that he was wrong about
in that interview because he also said
that he'd been praying for another 20
years of life despite only having about
one week of it left so i guess at the
very least
we now know that god didn't want to
listen to any more of jerry falwell's
[ __ ] either
and it is important to know
conservatives aren't remotely done here
they've already embarked on the next
fight with louisiana just this week
advancing legislation that would allow
prosecutors there who to charge those
who get abortions or provide them with
homicide
that bill like anti-abortion legislation
in several other states even defines
personhood as beginning from the moment
of fertilization which would arguably
criminalize in vitro fertilization and
forms of birth control and all of this
is happening even as other countries are
expanding reproductive rights even
ireland is now more progressive on
abortion than some u.s states and if you
are not up on your irish history that
was not always the case
and that is as much as i will weigh in
on irish history because i sound like
this
and it's it's not just ireland other
predominantly catholic countries like
argentina mexico and colombia have also
significantly expanded abortion rights
just two months ago colombia won a
massive court victory there two huge
celebrations
this is historic it brings us such
happiness because little by little we
are changing our history we finally
succeeded in having them allow us to
decide over our bodies we fought for
this for many years and clandestine
abortions took the lives of so many
women
that is truly inspiring to watch and
also quick shout out to the individual
who made a crocheted ski mask
with the letters a cab let this be a
lesson that you absolutely don't want to
[ __ ] with someone who has the patience
attention to detail and sustained anger
to crochet their resentment into a
handmade garment that is stamina that is
someone in the fight for the long haul
so clearly we in the states have a lot
of work to do right now right now both
in the short and the long term and let
me start with those in the most
immediate danger people who need an
abortion in states where bans are or are
about to be in effect you still have
options available to you and one good
way to find out what they are is to go
to the website i need an a.com it has
lots of info including what is permitted
where you live and where you can find
clinics and appropriate resources and if
you're struggling financially one of
those resources might be an abortion
fund which can help cover your expenses
if you want to access or support one of
those funds there are lots of them out
there like the brigid alliance which
helps abortion patients who are
traveling long distances to reach their
appointments and the lilith and yellow
hammer funds both of which help people
on the ground in impacted states but
these are clearly just stop gap
solutions to deal with an immediate
crisis long term we need elected
officials to stop tiptoeing around the
issue of abortion and take steps to
properly safeguard it now the dream
version of this would be a
constitutional amendment that will
support people's fundamental rights to
make personal decisions about
contraception pregnancy marriage and
family life but until then we're going
to need other legislation at the state
and federal level and while we're at it
we may now also need to show up all the
other rights supposedly guaranteed by
supreme court rulings from voting rights
to gay marriage because the fact is
under the current supreme court your
basic rights today could become crimes
tomorrow
and there are actually some small
opportunities for you on the horizon and
at least these four states abortion is
going to be on the ballot this year and
i know
you would probably rather eat shards of
glass than be told to vote one more time
especially if you've been keeping up
your end of the deal showing up to the
polls and holding your nose to vote for
a candidate you may not even like while
enjoying thousands of texts screaming it
is the most important election of your
lifetime donate 20 to the dnc right now
and you didn't text stop to quit once no
matter how much you wanted to and you
wanted to throw your phone in the
[ __ ] river
and look i also get why just vote is an
infuriatingly insufficient slogan when
voting rights themselves are under siege
i cannot defend the system we currently
have
but it is unfortunately the one we've
got right now so electoral victories are
going to be critical here but they also
must be followed by concrete actions by
those that we elect because republicans
if nothing else just grimly demonstrated
what committed action can actually
achieve they never accepted roe v wade
as final they played the long game and
not always fairly but they rallied their
base and relentlessly held their party
leaders accountable whether they liked
those leaders or not and then crucially
those leaders delivered for them because
they understood that voting is only
meaningful if the people who win
actually do what they [ __ ] promise
you
anti-choice advocates worked really hard
for a really long time to ensure that
roe would not be permanent but the thing
is its undoing doesn't have to be either
this week we have all been reminded of
what the most marginalized people in
this country have known for years that
freedoms are never guaranteed they are
hard-won and they are easily lost
progress requires a consistent sustained
struggle a willingness to disrupt
everyday life and actual courage from
the people that we choose to lead us in
short
we are all going to badly need to have
the same anger and the same willingness
for a long-haul fight
as the world's most hardcore knitter